hey guys how's it going so in this video
we're going to be talking about a book
that i read last week called deep work
by cal newport where he basically argues
that the ability to do
deep work is the most valuable
and the most rare skill and the super
competitive economy where businesses
would rather hire machines than people
and where businesses can basically hire
anyone around the world to do the work
[Music]
hi guys welcome back to the channel
if you're new here my name is dami i'm
an architect based in vancouver bc
on this channel i talk about
architecture design and productivity
and if you're interested in any of these
topics please consider subscribing
so in the book deep work count newport
goes into describing why deep work is so
important in this very distracted
society
and he also gives us five actionable
steps to
foster this ability to do deep work so
deep work is the ability to focus on
specific tasks
without distraction and they're usually
tasks that are cognitively demanding
and usually these sessions would last
anywhere between one to four hours
and by comparison shallow work is
something that's not very cognitively
demanding
it's something that's usually very
logistical
in nature so things like scheduling
meetings
responding to emails responding to
messages
and they can usually be done in a state
of distraction
and he says they don't bring much new
value to the world and they're very
easily replicatable
so in the past couple of decades our
communication tools
like social media instant messaging
meetings open offices have
exploded but our
ability to be selective on these tools
have
not he says that we
as long as these tools offer some
benefit
we don't really carefully consider
the negatives of these tools and most
companies
encourage multitasking they
expect a speedy response to emails
most companies have a lot of meetings
and especially as you get into more
senior roles you're
managing a number of different projects
rather than focusing on just one
and you end up doing a lot more
logistical tasks we don't actually have
the metrics
to tell us how this is hurting our
bottom line
and he calls this the principle of least
resistance
which means that without clear feedback
on how
something is hurting our business we
tend to just go with the behaviors that
are
the easiest in the moment and he says
that without a very clear idea of what
productivity means
our workforce goes back to this very old
industrial idea of productivity which is
doing a lot of stuff in a very
visible manner so for example if you
respond to
a lot of emails very quickly it's very
visible to everyone that you're on top
of it
as opposed to if you're researching on a
specific topic it might be hard for you
to show the results of that in the next
couple hours
and also shallow work is easier it
basically creates this illusion
of productivity um but doesn't actually
add that much value
and is very easily replicatable so what
this means is that
we live in a world where our attention
is very fractured
and the average person does very little
deep work on
a daily basis so apparently if you
constantly spend your time
in this state of shallow work your brain
permanently loses the capacity to do the
work
so the science behind that is that
there's apparently these things called
myelin in our brains and so whenever
you're doing a specific task
myelin builds up around the neurons that
are connected
to performing that specific task
and so this allows the circuits to
fire more smoothly um and so when you
keep
practicing one skill um
these circuits fire over and over again
and so
um you create this like layer of myelin
around the neurons and so this is how
the brain
basically cements a skill and so
apparently it takes years and years of
practice
um to get into the habit of
doing deep work and to increase
performance
and so that's really the difference
between
like your average joe and your
like expert performer
he also talks about this idea of
attention residue
so when you switch between tasks your
attention doesn't immediately switch
there's a part of your brain that's
still on the
task that you were doing before and
that's probably why so many productivity
gurus
encourage um time batching so
doing like a similar set of tasks all at
the same time
and like limiting context switching
so what this all means is i um to
perform at your peak level
you need like full concentration
without any distractions um and
to be able to work for an extended
period of time so how do you actually do
deep work
so he provides five steps that you can
implement into your life
um and basically there they design your
environment
and your life so that it makes doing
deep work a lot easier
so i've tried a couple of these myself
and
they've made a very positive change in
my life and i would
highly suggest you try them too but i
would also suggest maybe trying
one at a time because you know you don't
want to try
doing all of them and get discouraged
and
stop doing them right so number one
learn how to categorize tools
as deep or shallow so first you try to
imagine a goal or a desired outcome
in whatever aspects of your life it
could be your personal life it can be in
your professional life
for each of the tools that are consuming
your time
and energy ask yourself like is this
really helping me achieve my desired
outcome
and if the answer is no
he suggests quit the tool
which is obviously not super easy to do
but that is his suggestion very extreme
i know number two make quick structural
changes that encourages
deep work so this is a so this is
actually a pretty common trick that you
do
if you're trying to build new habits you
basically
design your environment so that it's
really hard for you to
get distracted and so here are some of
the structural changes that
cal newport recommends number one
disable all calls messages and
notifications
because nothing is that urgent
number two become hard to reach set auto
response to email
so that people don't have an expectation
that you're gonna respond
immediately number three quit social
media
he says just try quitting for 30 days
and don't even tell people that you're
gonna be leaving social media because
actually nobody will care
so you might have noticed that i haven't
posted anything on instagram for over a
month
and that is partially because i didn't
really have anything to post
but also because i was trying this
little experiment
and it has freed up a lot of free time
for me because
i used to whenever i was on transit i
used to go on instagram and scroll
through instagram
but now i listen to audiobooks so
i finished reading this book
this month i finished reading grit
by angela duckworth i also finished
reading the four hour work week
um so it's been a good good uh
transformation for me number four work
in a quiet place
i don't know who thought this open plan
office was a good idea
but most of our offices are now open
floor plans
and so it can be kind of hard to get
some focused work done
he suggests going to a private room or
the library to get your work done
or using noise cancelling headphones
number five
work at a quiet time so you might
remember from my
other video where i was talking about
trying to build up the habit of waking
up at six a.m
so i actually recently pushed my time to
5 a.m it was hard so i do my writing
uh just right in the morning and i
actually get to work around
7 a.m so i have a full hour and a half
where i'm in the office by myself
and so that's probably where i get the
most of my work done
in the day just being able to
not have any distractions for an hour
and a half
has been a total game changer number six
limit internet access during deep work
time
um so he suggests to gather everything
you need
before you start your uh deep work
session
um but i mean yeah i think this one's
probably
the most tricky because uh for
most research you need to use the
internet
he also suggests blocking off
websites that you know are problematic
for you
for me that would be facebook number
seven get visibility on
deep versus shallow time by minuting the
day
so he says that the best way to change
something
is to measure it so
he suggests keeping a log of everything
that you're doing
at like five to ten minute intervals
and so at the end of the day you can go
back and assess
how much time you spend being distracted
and how much time you
spent actually being productive and
focused number eight decide on a fixed
time when you finish your work and try
to stick to it
because you know shutting down for the
day means you're giving your brain some
time to relax
which will definitely help you focus for
the next day
this is probably one of the hardest
things to do because a lot of times your
work
just kind of bleeds into your day um
but yeah he says just really try to
commit to
a end of work time and
just really stick to it and the ninth
step
is train your attention so a lot of
these steps before
were ways you can eliminate shallow work
from your life
but he also suggests to actively
practice deep work and actively
practice focusing on a daily basis it's
kind of like meditation
you know as you're focusing on your task
if you see your attention
wander off just gently bring it back to
the initial object
he also suggests to become familiar
and comfortable with boredom so if
you're standing in the line
don't just immediately pull out your
phone to look at
things to do um he says just
you know just stand there and just
learn to be bored and the other thing he
suggests is practice thinking while
you're walking
which sounds like such a strange idea
but we usually
tend to listen to music or listen to
audio books while we're walking
and i feel like with the new
technologies
it be it has become rarer and rarer for
me
to just have moments where i'm walking
in silence
with my own thoughts and so i actually
started doing that more actively and
um i found it kind of hard
to just walk and think like i find that
it's
much easier for me to write down my
ideas where i can visually see them
but i can really see the value of this
practice so this is something that i'm
trying
to integrate a little bit more into my
life and then he also suggests
giving little workout exercises for your
mind
so for example learning a memorization
trick
or learning a new language
there is actually a really great forum
that i follow it's called the art of
memory
and people just like memory nerds talk
about their different
memory techniques and um i think
like 10 years ago i bought this course
called p
memory where you can basically train
yourself how to
have photographic memory
and i actually never ended up completing
the course because it was just like
way way way too tedious after a couple
of courses i could visibly
see the increase in my level of focus
because
it just required you to um
like a huge part of memory is just being
able to focus
and so that was it that was my summary
of the book deep work
and if you're interested in this topic i
would highly
recommend reading the full book because
he actually offers a lot of really
interesting
studies and examples and
stories of people who's um
really embodied this idea of deep work
in their lives and
how that has impacted their careers and
their professional lives
and their personal lives so yeah it's a
it's a good
uh fairly quick read i would love to get
your thoughts on this
um do you try to actively implement deep
work into your life
and um what do you think are the skills
that are gonna be super valuable and
rare in the next five to ten years
if you enjoy this video please give me a
thumbs up
it really helps other people discover
the channel
and if you haven't subscribed already
please consider subscribing
and if you want to be notified next time
i make a video you can hit the bell
button
and if you have any other book reviews
that you'd like me to do just leave it
in the comments below
and with that goodbye
you